there are some people sort of making
some sense through this actually one of
the guys making some sense through this
is glenn greenwald now glenn greenwald
is a lefty he is an edward snowden lefty
glenn greenwald and i used to fight on
twitter all the time glenn greenwald has
repeatedly called me racist
we've sort of made amends privately once
about a year ago so we don't go at each
other anymore but i have obvious
political disagreements with him is what
it is that's fine but i like to give
credit where credit is due
and here he is on fox talking about this
issue that i'm mentioning about media
resentment
you know i think it's the same reason
why you look at why they're so obsessed
with fox news sort of the one place that
has always existed
in the large mediocre system that
deviates from what the rest of the media
is typically saying like why can't you
have just one place where people are
questioning your orthodoxies and it's
because the ability to control
information is an incredibly powerful
instrument that everyone who tries to
obtain it wants to safeguard and so what
you see with joe rogan is he's built an
enormous audience bigger than
essentially everybody on television an
audience that's young and ideologically
diverse and he does often question and
dissent from the pieties they're
attempting to implant in the minds of so
many people and as their ratings decline
and their audience evaporates they're
looking to censorship as one of the ways
to maintain this stranglehold on our
discourse there's a huge component of
kind of resentment on the part of this
insular class and liberal enclaves that
nobody else is entitled to have
influence
yes glenn greenwald we're good to go man
uh by the way what's interesting
at another level about that is he's on
fox saying that okay now as he makes the
point they're always trying to destroy
fox right because fox is the only
counter place fox by the way is the only
network that will put me on and they put
me on completely uncensored i do things
live they've never once asked me to say
anything or not to say anything or
anything else when my first book came
out a couple of years ago we tried to
get on every other network nobody put us
on
it was a book defending liberalism but
actually they're anti-liberal that's a
whole other thing but what's interesting
about that is the guy that he's talking
to right there is a guy by the name of
howard kurtz and you might find it
interesting that howard kurtz used to be
a host on a network called cnn and you
know what show he used to host on cnn
it was a show called
reliable sources
yes he was the host on cnn of reliable
sources before brian stelter it was a
sunday morning show and i remember
watching it growing up and i thought it
was really interesting because i've
always been interested in media and he
would do this honest assessment of media
and critique of media and what are we
doing wrong and sort of let's look in
the mirror and figure out what's what i
don't remember exactly the controversy
that got him fired from cnn but then fox
news picked him up and there he is doing
an honest assessment of the media with a
guy glenn greenwald who is clearly not
on the right who is clearly not in
agreement with most of the stuff that is
said on fox news
okay but now it continues uh barry weiss
who of course was the new york times uh
op-ed person
who
famously left the new york times two
years ago
she defended
joe rogan and obviously i've been
somewhat critical of barry i'll get to
that in just a second
but she wrote ditto this is a tweet from
barry weiss this is a retweet of lex
friedman she wrote ditto grateful for
joe rogan and of course what lex said
was i stand with joe rogan it is not a
coincidence that the attacks calling him
racist come as pressure on spotify to
censor builds politicians and the media
profit on division and outrage they fuel
the extremes that make us believe we're
divided we're not we're in this together
so my only and i don't mean to be petty
about this but i do have to mention this
barry weiss thing because barry as you
know she wrote the original intellectual
dark web piece
in the new york times where she said
that if interviewers she was talking
about me and joe rogan specifically if
we talk to some of these scary people
and she was talking about mike cernovich
she was talking about alex jones and a
few others that we'd have to either be
cynical or stupid so she put that in the
new york times she called me and barry i
will talk directly to you and i've
texted you
so i'm not talking behind your back
you called me the next day
crying after the article came out
apologizing for putting it in there and
said that your editors forced you to put
it in there
so you were doing the same gatekeeping
that now you don't want done they're
forcing joe rogan to not talk to certain
people that's exactly what you did when
you were at the new york times i don't
mean to make this about you but why not
just admit that now you're free and
independent and on sub stack why not
just admit what you know to be true i'm
not making this up so that's that's just
a little sidebar and i apologize for
even bringing myself into this at that
level uh brett weinstein who of course
has been on my show many times and who
has survived uh cancelled culture and
you know literally survived being at
evergreen state university when kids
showed up with baseball that's he had a
good tweet about this he said joe rogan
is taking flak because he's over the
target i support him for the very same
reason every other person who
understands the relationship between a
free exchange of ideas and liberty
supports him
thanks joe rogan so of course
brett is right there and it is good to
see it is rare these days but it is good
to see some of the people that have been
through the machine uh not come out
sucking up to the machine and you know
standing up for what i know that they
believe in so props to brett on that one